[Music]
i can walk
[Applause]
thanks a lot andy appreciate it oh i
wasn't clapping for you it just echoes
in this empty room
ow i like that sound anyway what
happened was i'm backstage at the largo
theater that's where we're shooting the
show these days
and there's all this stuff back there
and i found that cane
and i just thought i got to use this
cane so i
came out and recreated that magical
moment
a little bit from willy wonka right a
little bit from sort of like a christian
revival meeting
yeah yeah it was it was good it was good
i felt i felt
your faith oh i guess i can take this
off
yeah why are you andy you've been
wearing a face mask around me
since 1994. well um
i i i didn't want you to see me doing
this
andy is just for you so you know andy
all the time i've known him now 27 years
has been making
sort of erotic gestures with his tongue
constantly
while talking and uh and and the face
mask has actually been a nice break from
that
yep yeah yeah okay that's that's not no
no
okay all right all right let's uh let's
take it easy there pal
well anyway andy as i say you're welcome
any time to move a lot closer if you
want yeah i'm lit
here it's nice it's comfortable
you might like to be a little closer to
me also
i'm farting you're good man maybe the
best man i've ever known
but i don't get out a lot now welcome to
our show terrific show today
uh one of our favorite people pat oswalt
on the show
uh tonight yeah nothing's more demeaning
to a comic than the sound of one hand
clapping
[Laughter]
good one